definitely the worst part about in
psycho
[Music]
so we don't leave anything behind here
in the environment the New Zealand
program actually is very thorough
intuited and it's not that bad as it
sounds
so I disagree Utley yes some disagree
actually some disagree I don't think so
I mean at least for Christology out they
are mean it's cold we have got - 10-15
something so normally it freezes very
quickly yeah okay so you need to hold
your nose maybe so this needs to be
really strong because if you're sitting
on the toilet in a storm you don't want
to have to flying away put in there
that's the bucket one of our most
important pieces of equipment
at nighttime when you really go to go
but you're not in proper gear and you
kind of got to do it in your tents and
around your sleeping bags much easier
for goddess you just got your bottle I
don't know I don't know how girls do I
never I never been this leaving think
you've no no let's technique to it not
in the sleep look just like everything
else in Antarctica take your time
aim is important even for ladies if you
try to fill your pee bottle too fast
you're unlikely to have perfect accuracy
if you really don't want to mess up the
place so if you get in there and you you
were brain it's like at home everyone
would would like to have a a clean
bathroom so why not keep it clean here
that tent looks actually now nicer than
my semi sleeping tent lunch lunch time
okay yes don't don't eat don't eat too
much yeah we are limited in our the
number of two packets
[Music]